today we're gonna look at the king we're
gonna look at how the King moves and
different things you want to think about
in the chess game regarding your King
the King is the most important piece in
a chess match if your check if your King
dies you lose the match so it's very
important even though he doesn't move as
much as some of the other pieces and
can't capture as much as some of the
other pieces he's still the most
important piece if he goes down you lose
so you always want to make sure that you
have King safety now let's go ahead and
take a look at the movement the movement
of the King can move one space in any
direction you can move backwards he can
move diagonal side-to-side any way he
can move one square at a time so early
on you want to make sure that your king
is safe because there's a lot of pieces
out on the board a lot of ways for him
to get attacked as you can probably tell
right now our King is exposed he's out
in the middle this is probably not good
you can probably tell if you compare
this to our King here our King is a lot
safer here but if you were to take all
the pieces off the board then the King
becomes much more powerful if all the
pieces aren't here then our King can
move around let's take a look at this
example here our King can become an
attacker he can get into the action
there's no way for the pawns at the
moment to really have a serious threat
to our King so later on in the game once
pieces start falling from the game you
can then get your King involved and you
want to have your King involved in the
endgame he can become a very very
valuable asset to your attack against
your opponent and also helping defend
some of your
hacking pieces you can use your king but
early on you want to make sure that you
have keen safety it's very important
especially when all the pieces are
roaming around the board trying to
attack King if you want to make sure he
is safe and secure now let's go over
what is it check you may say you know
I'm not really sure what a check is a
check basically is any time your king is
being attacked so let's say we look at
this position let's say white captures
on f7 we are attacking the King on ei
to move or he has to capture this piece
on f7 the King at the end of this turn
can no longer be attacked so he cannot
move his pawn AJ excuse me to h6 because
he's being attacked now he can move to
f8 or he can take this piece on f7
either way he has to get himself out of
check now if he has another piece let's
say we'll go ahead and add a bishop it
is completely okay for him to take with
another piece as long as he gets himself
out of check as long as his King is no
longer under attack then that's
completely fine now another thing you
want to look at is something called
stalemate and stalemate is when a king
cannot move and it's his turn so we'll
go ahead and take a look at it
let's get this set up here let's say
it's White's move and white moves his
King to e6
now it's blacks movement if you look at
it he has no scores where he can go
he can't move to d8 or f8 because the
pollen can capture he can't move to d7
or f7 because his King can capture and
he can't capture the pawn because the
King will capture the black has no moves
and so this is a stalemate basically
meaning it's a drawl and a lot of times
you'll see this even with a lot of
pieces you can have once I could have a
queen a rook two bishops and the other
side can just have a king and the game
can end in a draw and it's very
frustrating if you've ever come across
it where you have a complete winning
position and you get into a spot where
black cannot make any legal moves
meaning he can't move anywhere that his
King won't die you want to try to avoid
these so always make sure when you're
playing that you move so that the black
King can move so in this situation we
would simply move up our King to f6
he can't move to f8 he can't move to f7
because our King is here and our pawn is
attacking the f8 Square the only score
he has to go is d7 and then we can bring
our King to f7 and now the king is has
to retreat again he can't move back to
EA toward e8 because we're attacking
with our pawn and our King and once he
moves then remember we can promote with
our pawns and we can promote to let's
say a queen now we have an easy endgame
that we can win with King and King and
Queen verse King Wars before we made a
fatal flaw of putting black into
position where he could
so this is how the King moves early on
in the game you want to make sure he's
protected later on in the game you want
to bring him into the battle and use him
as an attacker hope this helped in your
games and enjoy